all right i think we can go ahead and
get started a couple practical
announcements
um the the talks are scheduled for about
40 minutes with about 15 minutes for
discussion but you're also encouraged to
ask questions during the talks
uh the best way to do that is probably
to post to the chat window or the q a
window and i'll be watching those i
think the speakers will also be watching
those
and uh uh if you're an attendee
as compared to a panelist and would like
to be upgraded to panelists just raise
your hand and someone will upgrade you
that will let you speak and be seen um
and otherwise oh the other thing is if
you're a panelist and posting to the
chat window
it's appreciated if you choose to post
to all panelists
and attendees it's not the default
setting but if you if you
do post it's nice everyone able to see
everything um
okay and without further ado let me
introduce our first speaker very briefly
as
ryan hoyla from carnegie mellon he's a
leader in developing sat solvers he's
well known for several things including
cuban conqueror method
uh the proof logging method which i
believe he's talking about today we'll
find out
and also he's one of the authors of a
2000 terabyte
math proof for the pythagorean theorems
pythagorean triples problem i should say
um which is billed as the largest math
proof
ever so uh without further ado ryan
please go ahead
um uh thanks for the introduction
um and uh yeah so i do have indeed
dubious honor of conserting the largest
math proof
ever but what we all know
is that we like to have short proofs
instead of long throws
and um in this talk i actually want to
kind of
uh talk with you about how can we
make short proofs using shot solvers and
so this will be the talk of today and uh
the strong the short proofs in order to
make them we
require strong proof systems uh i have
been
with several uh co-authors been working
on them i will present some of them
and then talk about how to find proofs
in these
systems
so the outline of this talk is as
follows first i will have
a kind of an introduction of proofs of
unsatisfiability this is probably
relatively easy to follow then there
will be
some more detailed talks uh first
however
we want to have proofs beyond resolution
because we are aware of the restrictions
of resolution
uh i will talk about new proof systems
to do this
and then i will talk about afterwards
finding short proofs in these proof
systems and then conclude with future
work and challenges
as sam already noted uh please in case
something is not clear
uh interrupt uh it's more important that
i think things are clear then and then i
will can adjust the
the things later um so please assuming
something not clear
or you have any other questions let me
know and then
i can interact
now first an introduction in the proofs
of
unsatisfiability so as
probably all of us know that um
certifying
satisfiability if there's a claim that
the formula is satisfiable
it's very easy to check right so we have
the formula
shown on the slide x or y not x or not y
and not not not y or not z
i will use this formula for how to talk
and
uh this is very easy to check right
we just have a satisfying assignment x
not y
or z and it's easy to check that this is
satisfiable
right the problem is what to do when
it's unsatisfiable
the very naive way would be to to build
a truth table
two to the power and entries but it's
not feasible
especially considering that we are
mostly frequently using formulas with
millions of variables
and then the question is can we make
proofs that are smaller than two to the
power n yeah the this isn't
this is typically not the challenge in
practice because the formulas are
relatively easy
but how can we make really small proofs
so that's kind of the
the main question of this talk
so what is a proof so in this
talk what i'm going what i consider
proof is simply a string
that certifies whether a formula is
unsatisfied
and the important part here is that
the string can be checked
in polynomial time in the size of the
string and the formula
but uh that doesn't mean
that we only that that still the proofs
can be exponentially large in the size
of the formula
right so but we do want to the the
checking to be
uh efficient
uh the by far the most common way of
doing uh proof and satisfiability
uh over the last decades has been
resolution proofs
and the resolution proof i will consider
simply a sequence of clauses
c1 to cm where every clause
is either contained in the formula or
produced by the resolution rule
and the resolution rule is the one shown
here on the slide
we have a clause containing a lateral x
we have
a clause containing a lateral not x and
we just
merge them and remove the complementary
pair
if the last clause in the sequence is
the empty clause the one without
literals
which by definition is unsatisfiable
then
the original formula isn't satisfied
and it's a well-known result that for
every unsatisfiable formula
there is a resolution proof
now just a small example so we have the
formula shown on top of the slide
and just below it there is a resolution
proof
it's a it's a sequence of clauses and
in this case i marked the
literals that are used for resolution
with blue if it's a positive literal
and red if it's a negative literal
and frequently it's more kind of
visualized using a resolution tree so
the same string can also be represented
by the
the the tree that you see here
and it's we can quickly check
that this is a valid proof by just
checking each of the resolution steps
now uh there are some drawbacks
so for many uh seemingly simple formulas
uh there are the famous pigeonhole
formulas jaden formulas
newsletter chessboards and so on and so
on
these are seemingly simple
but any resolution proof of them is
exponential in size of the site of the
formula
many shot solvers are now adding
techniques to kind of
uh solves formulas that uh
that have exponentially large resolution
proofs
and dedicated techniques that can solve
them quickly
and we want to express them uh kind of
specifically so we have a compact
expression ideally we want to kind of
have a
linear kind of size proof so linear in
the size of the solving type
and since the resolution proofs are
exponential
we cannot really use resolution for such
for such
proofs
uh so throughout the rest of the talk i
am going to use this notion of
a clausal proof it is still a
sequence of clauses or string
representing a sequence of clauses
and on the right we see a formula
consisting of four clauses and on the
right we see a proof
consisting also of four clauses
and what we're going to do is we're
going to check whether adding
say the first clause of the proof to the
formula preserve satisfiability
so we're no longer uh doing only
resolution
or a series of resolution steps uh
the only thing that you're considered
considering here is this
equivalent symbol which is
satisfiability preserving
and so what we want to do is we want to
check whether the addition of the clause
is satisfiability preserving and we can
do this in polynomial time
if we can do this for the first class of
the proof and the second one
and the third one and the final one and
the final one
is the empty clause then
uh since the empty clause is
unsatisfiable then by transitivity
the original formula had to be
unsatisfied
now so it's a very similar kind of in
nature as the resolution proofs although
we don't check with resolution
and we have this stronger notion of
satisfiability equivalence which i will
talk about more on future slides
yeah and so what we are
want to do is uh checking so-called
redundancy
and what is redundancy is just
satisfiability preserving the formula
with and without without without the
clause
are either both satisfiable or they're
both unsatisfiable
and we want this to be checked
efficiently
in polynomial time
and so now we're going to look about
which kind of clauses can we
add by some efficiently checkable
redundancy criteria
the most used one or most
clauses are actually redundant can be
checked with the following
polynomial time procedure which is known
as
reverse unit propagation so probably
most of us know what unit propagation is
if we have an assignment that falsifies
all literals in a clause except for one
which is unassigned
then we assign the remaining one to true
and we keep doing this
until fixed point the fixed point is
either that
there are no unit literals anymore or
there is a conflict
and we say that given a formula and a
clause
and let alpha be the assignment that
assigns all the literals in the clause
to false
then c is clause c is implied by unit
propagation
denoted by what's shown over here
if unit propagation on f
reduced by alpha reduce results
in a conflict
now let me briefly show
an example so we have an example formula
here with
eight clauses and four variables and now
consider the assignment that assigns a
to false and b to false then
this over here becomes a unit clause and
so we're forced
to make c true or false
now this becomes a unit clause so we're
forced to make d
false as well and now
this clause is falsified and so
uh a to false and b to false
by unit propagation results in a
conflict
uh why is this particularly interesting
all the clauses that are learned by cdcl
configurative and close learning
solvers have this properties that they
can be checked
by reverse unit propagation so we assign
everything in the clause to false
the unit propagation and their edit
results in a conflict
and also the nice thing is is that we
can actually produce
a resolution proof from this by
starting with the falsified clause as
shown here
a or c or d and then for each of the
clauses that became unit
we do resolution so first we do this
with b
or c or not d obtaining a or b or c
and then we do resolution with the other
unit clause
a or b or not c and then we obtain a or
b
which is the complement of the
assignment
and so the clause learning and cdcl
solvers can all be explained by reverse
unit propagation and
we can use this unit propagation as a
polynomial time procedure
to check that the clause a or b is
redundant
okay so this concludes kind of the
introduction are there any kind of
questions i think this is probably the
easiest part to follow but
still i i wanted to be clear
yeah so amy asked whether claus is
considered redundant if it removes some
satisfying assignments
but not all and the answer is yes so
any clause that preserves satisfiability
so the formula with
and without a clause they are both
satisfiable unsatisfiable
is considered redundant and that means
that if
you if a clause removes all but one of
the satisfying signs
it's still considered redundant
any other questions brian quick quick
question
for an unsatisfiable formula any clause
that you add would preserve
unsatisfiability right
right so therefore every clause is
redundant
yeah for instance variable formulas
every clause is redundant but
the main question is how can we check
this in polynomial time
all right so this is the thing that but
every class is redundant the main
question is
how can we find clauses for which we can
check the redundancy in polynomial time
if every class is written why do you
have to check it you can just
otherwise you don't know because you
don't know that the formula isn't
satisfiable
okay fair enough
any other questions okay now let's
continue uh
with proof systems that go beyond
resolution
first kind of in the traditional proof
systems everything
that is learned or deduced is inferred
and so for example we have already seen
the
the resolution rule and also with uh
modus ponens
uh if you have c or x and d or not
not x we can learn c or d if we have a
and a
implies b we can learn b
and all these inference rule they reason
about the presence
of other facts so if the premises are
there
then we can infer the conclusion
with all the proof systems we're going
to see from now on
we are doing something different so
we're no longer
reasoning about presence but we're going
to reason about
absence um and this is required when we
kind of want to
add clauses that actually remove
solutions
so what these proof systems will have is
that they only require
uh that the prese that that we preserve
satisfiability
and in order to do this uh we need to
reason about absence
and this is what we call
interference based proof systems why are
we calling this interference-based proof
systems because
um in a normal for a normal formula we
can have
uh we can add a clause a c
that removes some solutions uh or so
if we for example we have a uh sorry
back up we can learn across
two clauses and if they are based
on presence then if we can learn them
independently we can add them both at
the same time
and we still are fine however if we only
talk about
preserving satisfiability if we learn
two clauses that we
could add individually but one might
move some
part of the solution another one might
remove some
other part of the solutions and together
they remove all solutions
so we cannot add both at the same time
right so this is something
which in which interference-based proof
systems
differ with inference proof systems
and this might sound new
but actually this reasoning about
absence is
as old as sot solving if you go back to
the early work by
uh by davis and putnam and logman and
lavland
they already had the so-called pure
literal rule
if a literal not x is not occurring in
the formula
then we can learn the unit clause x
and learning this unit clause x might
actually remove solutions
another proof system
from the 60s that reasons about absence
is the extended resolution proof system
that proof system says that if a
variable x does not occur
or as shown on the slide if the literal
x and the literal not
x do not occur in the formula then we
can add a definition
that defines x based on
literals existing in the formula so for
example we can
add the definition x is the end
of of literals a and b and a and b
occur in the formula but x does not
under current
and this could be kind of considered
a first interference based proof system
although it's kind of in between i will
talk about it more later
because you do need to reason about
absence because
it's not allowed to add this definition
uh if x is already present
and this proof system is very powerful
actually there are no lower bounds known
for extended resolution
so just to give an example of the
strength of extended resolution
there is this well-known pigeonhole
problem so we ask whether we can put m
plus one pigeon in n holes with at most
one pigeon per hole
this is clearly not possible and
any child would probably of say four
years or older would
notice if you ask it in this way
but if you translate it into say
propositional logic
then all the pigeons get in holes
get different names and resolution
proofs
are exponential on the number of pitches
but excellent resolution proves
are polynomial size and they have been
constructed by cook
in 67. so
accident resolution is very powerful
and there's very short menu approves
however
there is still no method to find such
excellent resolution proofs for example
for the pigeonhole formulas
automatically the reason is that
extended resolution allows you to add
definitions
based on existing variables but the
search space for these definitions
is enormous in size and it's very
difficult to come up with effective
definitions
so there have been several approaches
for example pairs of literals that occur
frequently in conflict clauses
we add definitions of
of such pairs this helps somewhat
but still the proofs are still
exponentially large
uh one of the problems that that i think
is there is that it's so difficult to
compute proofs to compute to find the
right definitions
so can we do have strong proof systems
without new variables
and the first kind of approach in this
direction
was uh the notion of block losses
okay so what's a blocked clause
a blocked clause is a closest block
c or x on the trial x if all
the resolvents are so all the clauses
containing not
x are a tautology
let's consider a small formula a or b
and a or not b or not c and not a or c
the first clause is not blocked because
if we
have for example if x is in this case a
we
can resolve it with this clause not a or
c
and then we have a clause b
or c which is not a tautology
however uh a
a in the second clause not c in the
second clause
and c in the third clause they are
witnesses that the second and the third
clause are blocked
and actually if we remove these clauses
then we can also remove
a or a or b because then a and
b become also witnesses of blockness
and so for this formula we can actually
remove all the clauses
and thereby showing it satisfiable
but what we are interested more in is
that we can actually also add block
clauses
and notice that we doesn't require
x to be a new variable
and the theorem by coleman is that
adding or removing block clauses
preserves satisfiability or
unsatisfiability depending on whether
you add
or remove clauses so a block clause is a
redundant clause
and block clauses
generalize the extended resolution rule
noticed so this was the extended
resolution rule
and what you can observe here is that
x and not x in the first and second and
third clause
are weaknesses that the clauses are
blocked
so first for example if we add disk
clause
x is not x is not occurring so it's
clearly blocked
but then if we add afterwards not x or a
then it's blocked because
resolving it with this clause results in
a tautology and the same holds for b
so block clauses can
simulate excellent resolution but it can
also do things
because it can also you can add block
clauses that are not using a new
variable
the nice thing is that block clause
elimination has been a very powerful pre
and in processing technique
um and for example it can simulate many
circuit optimization techniques and uh
the largest meth proof ever what sembus
kind of used in the introduction
actually we use we remove lots of
redundant clauses by
block loss elimination and therefore
make the problem much more simple
so arguably the most popular
interference-based proof system is d-red
uh and i want to mention it here but i
don't want to go too much into detail
here
so that's why there's no definition
there yet
the most important thing to know about
d-rat is that you can efficiently check
it
that the proper that the clause has this
so-called red property which i will talk
about later
the clauses are not implied and
and that the addition of red clauses
preserve satisfiability
also uh what d-red makes different from
other proof systems that we discuss so
far is that we also allow
the deletion of clauses
this was initially done to make proofs
more that we can check them more
efficiently
[Music]
but it's also it introduces new clause
addition options as well
now although i don't because
i just want to mention the definition i
try to make it as simple as possible
here
just kind of to give you kind of some
feeling how it works
so a clause c or x is a red clause
or a longer resolution asymmetric
tautology
on the lateral x with respect to a
formula f
if for every clause containing the
complement
the resolvent c or d
is implied by unit propagation so maybe
you recall
the reserve unit propagation that we had
before
we set everything to false unit
propagation results in a conflict
now we have something similar here but
this looks much more like the block
clause definition so in the block clause
definition we had
everything the same except that implied
by unit propagation
was a topology so what was
implied by a tautology there is now just
replaced by implied by unit propagation
so every resolvent if we ascend
everything to false unit propagation
results in the conflict
and this is very powerful to express in
processing techniques
and and so on um
i don't want to go further into detail
here but i want you to kind of give you
the
most popular interference based proof
system which is also used
in the sub competitions
now let's look at some other strong
proof systems which are going to use for
for later on um there's a lot of proof
systems have been proposed
and especially in the 60s there were
lots of famous proof systems have been
proposed
and a selection has been shown on the
slide
on the left and they are shown
for in increasing strength so
[Music]
every if there's an arrow from one proof
system to another one it's it's
it's strictly stronger and
uh what we see here is that uh we have
all these proof systems
um with excellent resolution at the top
and we have here in the middle general
resolution
and uh cdcl finds proofs in this
proof system and so it seems to be kind
of
in the in the middle of uh
uh being off of its strength
but also as we know now we can it's
they're very efficient methods to find
proofs in general resolution using cdcl
uh it is my feeling that
these proof systems are mostly designed
with the
question of whether there exists a short
proof
for for certain formulas in mind but i
think the more important question
for practice is whether we can
find short proofs and so
what i've been working on with various
co-authors
is actually to make proof systems that
are generalizations of extended
resolution so the new proof systems
actually extended resolution is at the
bottom
and we have these proof systems that are
generalizations
so what i mean with the the dotted arrow
is that
every proof in this system is also
proven this system
but we can there's polynomial
simulations between all of them
and so here we see for example the red
proof system which i discussed on the
prior slide
and uh here we have
a new process proof system called set
propagation redundancy
which i think is also again at a nice
sweet spot
for finding short proofs in a stronger
proof system
and we call this procedure sdcl
which is short for satisfaction-driven
clause learning
okay um i think so
nicola let me because i think this goes
um
uh i think this would be a good question
to kind of discuss at the end of the
talk
because i kind of want to kind of kind
of show late but i think it's a
good point to um discuss
other proof systems that don't have new
variables because actually all the
groups just sorry
okay thanks ryan um
there's a quick question here can you
say that these proof systems are
strong you know you're not saying
they're stronger than extended
resolution right they're
all polynomially equivalent to it yes
unfair
yeah but there are generalizations like
for example with the block clauses we've
seen that any block clause proof
of any extended resolution proof is a
block clause proof
but not any block clause proof is an
excellent resolution proof
so it generalizes the concepts and
there's a polynomial
uh simulation
um so um yeah so that's what the arrow
means
um another question if i can just
ask you have spr and sdcl on the same
line but they're not
they're not the same are they or
i think sdcl is a procedure yeah so sdcl
is a procedure
that finds proofs in uh in in the sbr
proof system similar to that cdcl finds
proofs in the general resolution proof
system
okay yeah so so they're not the same
this is
a decision procedure similar to cdcl for
general resolution okay is it known
whether sdcl
simulates extended resolution
maybe that's a good question um
so what what exactly
that's a good thing for after this yeah
because every every so every
uh sbr proof is also an extended
resolution proof i think uh
mariah what sam is asking is just just
as it took a while to prove that cdcl is
polynomially equivalent to resolution
it's possible that we don't yet have a
proof for
sdcl is polynomially equivalent to spr
yeah and they really hope so but it may
not yeah
even under uh uh non-deterministic
branching
yeah and the thing here is also that um
sdcl as it's currently kind of
implementation and proposed does not
introduce any new variables right and we
don't know the strength
of offset propagation redundancy if we
don't allow new variables
all right so this is all what what what
sam calls spr minus
but let me also for the sake of time uh
continue and we can discuss
these and other questions um
later so
i want you to give you kind of some
impression of how this kind of works
and i try to make an example that
hopefully
makes it somewhat clear and for that i
use
the problem of mutilated chessboards
so what's the mutilated chessboard so we
have a chessboard
and we take away two opposite corner
cells
and then we ask whether the remaining
chess board can be filled by dominoes
which cover two squares each
the question is clearly no why
two opposite corner cells of any chess
board have the same color if we take
them away
then one color occurs more frequently
than the other color
every domino covers one white and one
black cell
and so clearly we cannot do this
however for automated reasoning
techniques such as sot
this is extremely hard problem because
it is not aware of this nice chessboard
pattern
and it's not aware that one color occurs
more frequently than the other one
now let's have a look what
proof systems are doing with this so uh
consider that we have
the a solver that produces the the
assignment shown on on the right here
and
what happens in the general learning
technique so
what we see here on the left is actually
what a cdcl software would do
in this situation so it's able
so we had 30 dominoes placed we have an
assignment of 30 dominoes now there's a
conflict
and it is able to uh
simplify it to an assignment with 14
dominoes and that's actually the 14
dominoes shown on the slide so cdcl
uh uh gets us from 30 dominoes
to 14. so it's uh
an improvement but it's still
if you have a larger board this will
still result in exponentially large
proofs
the interesting thing what the new proof
systems allow you to do
is and it's actually also which we
observed in practice when we implemented
this
is that if you give the same assignment
to
the sdcl which i haven't described yet
and i will only do later in
to some degree but the important thing
here is that
sdcl will can give you back just two
dominoes
and actually it gives you back these two
dominoes
and so what is actually going on here
so what the new proof systems allow you
to do is that
assuming that we can cover the entire
grid and there are two horizontal
dominoes on top of each other
and then we can also uh
cover the entire grid where these two
horizontal dominoes
are replaced by two vertical ones so
without loss of generality we can say
that
there is no uh
two dominoes at that spot uh
two horizontal dominance on that spot
and we can add it as a clause
and this is what what the procedure will
give you i
there's a lot of details going on here
and i just want to give you the high
level picture here
but the proof system allows you to
actually learn this binary clause
instead of this clause of length 14.
and more in general so what the the
proof system is actually allowing you to
do
is that as soon as you see two
horizontal dominoes on top of each other
it says okay i can block this because
then i can replace it by two vertical
dominoes on the same location
and we can do this over the entire board
of of
uh of the board additionally
if we have two vertical dominoes next to
each other with a horizontal one on top
then we can replace it by two vertical
ones next to each other with a
horizontal one below it
if both of these patterns are blocked
over the entire
grid then the number of
possible assignments goes from
exponential to linear
and the cdcl solver will quickly be able
to
to find to refute those linear uh
remaining positions so
by adding these binary ternary clauses
we can actually
have linear size proofs for
mutated chessboards
is so this is a very high level kind of
description i will come
next slides go into more detail but are
there any questions at this point
okay in that case uh let me continue so
this was kind of a kind of an
overview of these uh proof systems that
go beyond resolution i will go into some
more detail in the next section
um so actually i wanted to make this
kind of clear
with something that we discussed earlier
in the summer in the workshop is altar
keys
so what is an altar key an alter key is
a non-empty assignment
[Music]
such that every clause that is touched
by the assignment is also satisfied by
the assignment
and kind of the easiest
author keys are pure literals and
satisfying assignments
and so for consider we have this formula
over here
that was the one on the earlier slide a
pure literal is not c
over here so that's an auto key and this
is the satisfying assignment that we
have
is also an altar key we're mostly
interested
in altar keys that are not of this
uh somewhere in between them
purely trolls and satisfying assignment
but they hartley or kirk say in the wild
um and the nice thing ab the nice
theorem about
alter keys is that if we have an alter
key for formula f
then the formula f and f alpha are
satisfiability equivalent
so again alter keys hardly happen in
practice
but what does happen a lot in practice
is the so-called notion
of conditional alter keys so we now have
an assignment
that consists of two parts a conditional
part in an auto key part
and an assignment is called the
conditional alter key for formula f
if the alter key part is a
non-empty alter key for the conditional
part
again we have our formula over here
and let x be the conditional part
and not y be the alter key part and so
the condition auto key is x or not y
and this is a conditional alter key for
f
if because
so this is the formula under the
condition so it removes both
satisfied both the clauses containing x
and y is now satisfying
and not why is satisfying this the
remaining clause
and although
[Music]
altar keys hardly occur conditional
alter keys you encounter
all the time
now how can we use this so
given a conditional alter key
for formula f what we can do is we can
add the following uh constraint to the
formula
that the condition implies the auto key
yeah
so so we negate everything here
so we negate everything in the in the
condition and then
for each of the literals in the altar
key we can add a clause
and so in the above example we will
learn
uh not x x implies y
which is the clause not x or not y
now what's the relationship of what we
have been talking about before
so first in order to see this is the the
key thing that actually will be used
in sdcl is the so-called positive redux
so the positive redux is a formula
based on another formula so we have a
formula f and an assignment alpha
and the positive reduct is a formula
that contains
the complement of the assignment so all
the literals
negated and
from all the clauses in the formula that
are satisfied by
the assignment it contains only the
literals that are assigned
by ps by the assignment
uh so let me give two examples to kind
of make it a bit more clear
so we have our formula that we have been
using throughout this talk
and so let the first assignment be just
assigning x to true so then the clause
will be not x
and so this is not x over here and from
these two clauses
we only use the signed literals which in
both cases just
x so we have two unit clauses and this
formula didn't satisfy
now consider a second assignment x
and y so the clause will be not x or not
y
the positive redux will be not x or not
y which is
clause c2 and from
the formula the variables that have been
assigned
and this is x or y and x or not y
and this formula is satisfiable
and now without going into
too much detail but the important thing
here
is that given a formula an assignment
every satisfying assignment of a
positive reduct
is a conditional attack
and so um
this but so there's a lot of things that
kind of
uh i cannot go into detail here
but we can use this uh
assignment so if we use kind of what
i've shown here on this slide
the clause not x or not y if we add this
clause
to the formula it would actually block
this assignment so what
i'm going to tell a little bit more but
in short detail
a little detail is if we have this
assignment alpha
and we construct a positive reduct and
it's satisfiable
we can add a clause that blocks the
current assignment
and so this is what what how how we're
going to use this
now uh let me show you how this
satisfaction driven close learning works
on a very high level
so first what is cdcl most of us
probably have seen this now over
at some point cdcl what does it do it
picks a variable essentially to a true
value simplifies the formula
and it does this until you hit a
conflict so this is the main loop
which kind of consists uses 90 of the
render
only at that point the reasoning starts
to kick in
and we add a clause that
[Music]
blocks the current assignment and then
we kind of start over
what is going on in sdcl
is we have it's very similar to
cdcl except the one over here
so in every current assignment that we
have in the formula
we ask whether there is a
another state it is at least as
satisfiable and in our case we actually
ask
we ask this question by running the
positive reduction
is the positive reduction of the formula
and the current assignment satisfying
if that's the case and notice that this
is an mp complete check because we just
constructed a new satisfiable formula
satisfiability formula then we block the
current assignment
and we continue
yeah so sorry that so that um
because of kind of the limited time i
kind of only kind of describe it on this
high level
but we kind of use kind of conditional
ultra key reasoning
to kind of block things and this
actually gets us
so-called spr clauses
and this procedure is
[Music]
able to
get us very short uh proofs for the
pigeonhole formulas
we also it's able to to get us short
proofs for the cheating formulas
mutated chessboards it's uh it really
depends a bit on the size it's not
completely working for all sizes yet
but for example for the pigeonhole
formulas we only find
proofs that use only binary and
and unit clauses and so we can
use this procedure to kind of use kind
of this
this reasoning to get very short proofs
for these heart formulas
okay let me kind of uh
kind of conclude and then we can and can
take questions
[Music]
um
yes so paul beam asked which so if you
have a satisfying assignment can you
know which part is the author key yeah
so everything that is
uh common with alpha will be the
conditional part
and everything which is not common with
alpha is the other key part
so uh what's the future so let me kind
of
only kind of focus on these points we
have now
uh not only these new proof systems we
also have verified checkers for these
proof systems
um uh
and the nice thing is what we can have
now what i also heard from solver
developers is that we can actually
they don't care too much about
correctness of completeness of the
solvers
but they just produce the proofs and it
allows them to make solvers
more complex and more efficient because
we can easily check whether
the reasoning is is correct
and so we can have now this very complex
and efficient tools
while having full confidence in the
results
the the strong so the verified proofs
are now
in different proofs proof fear improving
systems including acl2 isabel
cook and kkml and also what is i think
is very nice is that these
[Music]
checkers are actually used in industry
as well
so before kind of i actually
have the last part of the talk is
actually only already kind of some
questions
i didn't were able to talk too much
about the
the proof systems here but can we find
lower bounds for proof systems
if they don't have new variables
and i think one of the interesting open
questions is what is the power of
conditional
auto key reasoning
can we also simulate
without new variables other of the kind
of classical proof system include a
frayer and cutting planes
and can we design even stronger proof
systems um
sam also in his paper with new actually
has this substitution redundancy which
is actually a generalization of uh
propagation redundancy
so can we even make stronger ones
and on the practical side there's also
lots of open
questions which are good heuristics
how can we make the the clauses that we
learned using
sdcl as small as possible can we do
something stronger than the positive
redux
can we use local search and
uh constructing the positive redux is
currently
quite costly uh how can we do this more
cheap
so these are just kind of questions i'm
happy to talk about any of them
um but uh maybe there are some other
questions from the audience that that
are more
kind of interesting
so this concludes my talk and i'm happy
to go into
answering questions
thank you very much i'll uh wave my
hands as it's clapping for everyone
so a very very nice talk and uh we have
some time left for questions
uh so there's a couple in the chat
window so why don't we start with that
those amir asks is there a connection
between proof systems and symmetry
breaking
um to some extent
there so i think
um so with symmetry breaking what we
have is so
if we have a solution uh uh maps onto
another solution by symmetry
then the the proof systems allow you to
kind of to break it
to express the symmetry breaking um
but i think that the proof systems are
are stronger so what you
i think on a very high level is that if
you you add a clause
if you can say that for example for a
certain assignment
if there's another assignment that is at
least satisfiable
uh for symmetry breaking it is that you
have one satisfying assignment and
there's another branch with another
satisfying assignment and then you can
block it
but in in principle this would be
stronger because
this branch might not have a satisfying
assignment and you can still block it
because the because reasoning allows you
to say okay there's another one that is
more satisfiable and that one might have
a solution so
in for symmetries this is there is
um it's symmetric right there's a
solution here solution there
for this proof system it's not
necessarily that the one that you're
kind of blocking
is actually uh has a solution so there
it's frequently so one of the the powers
is that you can do symmetry breaking
which allows you to for example have
quick refutations for example for the
pigeon hole but
these proof systems are stronger and
that they can do things i think that
symmetries cannot do okay
good and fajin has a question
yes so marin could you clarify briefly
the
relationship between the block clause
elimination and extended resolution
so i could certainly see that the
extended resolution
clauses are blocked clauses but how
would you
simulate a proof in extended resolution
with block clauses that i didn't
understand
um so as soon as you have so the proof
of extended resolution
of block clauses is simply you add these
clauses
uh so you you as soon as you want to
introduce the definition
instead of introducing the definition in
some way you just
add the clauses uh as redundant clauses
to your formula
okay so i see okay yeah so it's just
um because in these causal proof systems
just everything is reduced to the
addition and removal of clauses
and when extended resolution decides to
add a definition you just
add the block clauses okay i see
okay oh
uh karen has a question
oh it's a comment on on symmetry um
mutilated chessboard is fully symmetric
i think adding high-level symmetry info
should solve it for any size
up right
uh let me see so
um that i would actually be very
interested to so
so to see how how you would do the
symmetry breaking
um but so the clauses that actually are
kind of added here right
they would see them as kind of some form
of symmetry
breaking but uh
i don't i'm not actually i'm not sure
whether i tried this but
i'm don't think that existing symmetry
breaking techniques
actually solve them efficiently not
existing symmetry breaking
marine what i'm thinking of is when you
mentioned introducing variables
you know that actually takes advantage
of some structure in the formula
you know the formula has some structure
to it you know the hierarchical
decomposition of the formula
symmetry is also another part of
structure i think just adding kind of
some some additional info about the uh
structure of the formula
um and in the case the reason that
symmetry breaking didn't work in general
is because the
formulas that we apply simply breaking
to are not fully symmetric
and and finding the uh symmetries you
know is
a uh does not sometimes work the
symmetry breaking predictors do not
work with the uh cdcl procedure but if
you know that all of the
um cells in the in the chess board are
symmetric all of the tiles are symmetric
um i haven't done it but i think you can
add
some global constraint that basically uh
not just
eliminates
not not mapped solutions to solutions
but also maps non-solutions are not
solutions
um yeah but act so i mean also mentioned
in the and that's that's that's a
correct observation from armen is that
the cnf is not symmetric right
and so that's what i'm saying is if the
cnf is not symmetric
um that means the formula itself is not
symmetric but the actual
function is describing the uh the board
is fully symmetric so the syntactic
symmetry is not full but the semantic
symmetry is full
yeah but um i think it would be a nice
challenge to kind of come up with
some symmetry breaking techniques for
for this problem right
but i think the nice thing about the new
pro systems is actually
that it comes up with with this domino
argument
automatically when we run the sofa for
the first time
it actually gave us this these patterns
and i think the important thing is that
we can't find
such arguments automatically and
um because of course if you
because if you write this as a with
cardinalities
then you can solve it instantly right
because the number of white
is is large in the number of black so
of course what i'm confused about is why
is it working for pigeon holes and not
for this because the same argument
should vote right
yeah but the reason is that because of
the
uh because the sim the pigeon hole are
are fully symmetric
also the the sulfur kind of quick
because probably does a more symmetric
search
than for the for the mutilated chess
boards and so
it should with the right heuristics it
will be able to find them
but we don't have these heuristics yet
okay thanks
let's do one one last question from paul
uh
he asks does spr use clause deletion
also
so uh we have uh approved so the
um the proof system that kind of i i
talked about
uh i talked only about
the clause edition aspect but all of the
proof systems that kind of we're using
in practice
combine both close edition and close
deletions also we have this kind of dspr
proof format
which which combines it so in uh
i think the the short mutual chess
boards i have they don't
require deletion and there are no clause
deletion steps
uh but they can be easily be combined
is that your question
uh yes thanks because you would only
mention the the the clause edition
yeah because close edition is the only
thing that's required
but i think in practice you want to have
proof systems that also support the
deletion
okay um
all right there's another comment from
paul about the symmetries for mutilated
chessboard or only rotational since the
distance from corners breaks symmetries
uh i think we've already covered that so
we're
if there's no other quick questions i
think we're running a little over on
time so maybe it's time to move on
thank you again very much for the very
interesting talk
and thank you really